nous sommes maintenant aux compagnies de
l'ena star au double ceva bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous répondez à la
question depuis l'ukraine depuis une
petite ville située à 60 km de la
capitale kiev dont vous êtes parti votre
mari est resté sur place qu'elles sont
d'abord les dernières informations dont
on dispose et s'agissant de votre
capital
bonjour à tous merci pour l'intérêt sur
nos pays sur notre liberté
pour le moment ma famille mes enfants
mais ma mère hager et encore quatre
familles de mer de mes amis avec tous
les enfants à tous sont ici dans un
petit village c'est la rive gauche de
notre mieux et prairies mais quand même
c'est calme nous sommes vraiment heureux
parce que chez nous nous entendons
seulement les bruits des avions et
parfois des explosions mais beaucoup
beaucoup de mes amis sont restés à
guillet faire il passe la troisième nuit
dans les refuges sert je ne peux pas
imaginer que tout ça se passe avec nous
maintenant dans notre pays
vous savez la guerre a commencé à 5 à 5
heures du matin le vent relevant que le
24 février et non je suis de kiev est
moi et ma famille ne se sont réveillés
avec avec le bruit des explosions des
jeux je n'ai jamais pensé que tout ça va
va être akiyev à ma ville natale
je ne peux pas dire que que nous avons
la panique bien sûr on a peur bien sûr
mais vous savez à toutous tous tous mes
amis beaucoup beaucoup de populations
civiles a va battre contre les ennemis
j'ai un doudou justement ma seconde
question pardonnez-moi sur par exemple
ou au kef où qui est resté à kiev il
fait partie de ceux qui ont pris les
armes
à beaucoup de mes amis font ça mais mon
mari il est il travaille pour l'état lui
et ses collègues ont maintenant akiyev
au boulot et il défend
notre pays mais je ne peux pas dire plus
d'informations parce que c'est c'est
vraiment c'est pas les les batailles
dans les rues mais quand même c'est
aussi très très important pour le pays
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
perspectives de pourparlers dont on
parle et vladimir poutine et volodymyr
zelensky pas en biélorussie visiblement
selon les ukrainiens qu'est ce que vous
en pensez comment voyez-vous la chose à
nous espérons que la guerre va finir
mais nous sommes nous sommes je moi
personnellement mes amis nous croient je
crois en nos forces militaires et je
suis sûr que nos forces militaires bon
avons protégé mon pays mais bien sûr
nous avons besoin de votre aide
premièrement de l'aide de l'europe parce
que pour le moment je crois que
l'ukraine c'est con comme le mur contre
contre la russie et toute l'europe parce
que nous battons pour la pour la paix
dans l'europe c'est comme ça qu'on que
moi et ma famille pense maintenant et
j'espère bien sûr que la guerre fille va
finir est non notre président va faire
je ne sais pas faire quelque chose mais
nous ne sont pas nous n'ont pas peur
helmand j'espère que tout va finir mais
je voulais vivre dans mon pays je ne
veux pas quitter le pays pour moi et
pour ma famille pour les enfants je veux
rester ici et défendre le pays merci
beaucoup pour votre témoignage lena star
au double c va merci